un disco rojo gira con una velocidad
angular o mega y un punto en el
perímetro se mueve con una velocidad v
esta es la velocidad angular y esta es
la velocidad típica ambos son vectores
por eso están en negritas un disco azul
gira con una velocidad angular 2 o mega
es el doble de la velocidad angular por
lo que el ángulo cambia el doble de
rápido con un punto en el perímetro que
se mueve a una velocidad 2 v esta
velocidad es el doble de la velocidad
lineal del disco rojo y nos preguntan
cuál disco tiene el radio más grande
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta después lo
resolveremos juntos visualicemos lo que
está ocurriendo aquí tenemos el disco
rojo que luce así dibujamos el radio de
este círculo le llamamos r rojo sabemos
que un punto acá tiene una velocidad v
que dibujamos en esta dirección también
sabemos que tiene una velocidad angular
igual a un mega por otra parte tenemos
el disco azul lo dibujamos con un radio
arbitrario porque aún no sabemos cuánto
mide su radio real
este es el radio del círculo azul que
llamamos r azul y la velocidad de un
punto similar aquí es igual a 2 v este
vector lo dibujamos el doble de alto y
tiene una velocidad angular de 2 o mega
esto nos dice qué tan rápido está
rotando cómo podemos saber cuál disco
tiene el radio más grande la clave para
resolver esta pregunta está en la
relación entre la magnitud de la
velocidad angular y la magnitud de la
velocidad una forma de pensar en esto es
que la magnitud de la velocidad angular
noten que no pongo la flecha arriba pues
estamos hablando de la magnitud de la
velocidad angular multiplicada por el
radio va a ser igual a la magnitud de la
velocidad o igual a la rapidez para
encontrar la magnitud de la velocidad
angular si dividimos ambos lados entre r
la magnitud de la velocidad angular va a
ser igual a la rapidez oa la magnitud de
la velocidad entre r por otra parte
podemos decir que el radio es igual a la
rapidez entre la magnitud de la
velocidad angular para el caso del
círculo rojo
podemos decir que el radio rojo es igual
a v / omega y para el círculo azul
podemos decir que el radio azul es igual
a la rapidez que es 2 v / la magnitud de
la velocidad angular que es 2 o mega
noten que estos dos se cancelan y nos
queda v / omega estos dos círculos
tienen el mismo radio escribimos que
ambos tienen el mismo radio nos vemos en
otro vídeo